zasha portal is training to be a circus
performer he also has Down syndrome a
genetic disorder that affects millions
of people around the world including
50,000 in Germany it's difficult for
zasha to communicate verbally with
others he hopes that performing in the
circus will give him more
self-confidence
then slice and often put your other foot
in the middle to Sasha my doesn't and
it'll work see that's great
every Thursday Sasha arrives for
practice at the zonan circus in Berlin
the featured performers have down
syndrome today he's working on
acrobatics with his partner Anya Maria
fish' sasha has been coming here for 17
years they don't want to be dismissed as
disabled they'd rather be accepted for
their artistic abilities coach michelle
piggle and raised is putting everyone
through their paces they've got a big
performance soon so you go ok Sasha
Maria this is really important what are
you matter we run so well that's exactly
right on looks a lot better nice easy
does it like you're floating either my
own ego Moreno try it again Zasha
learned here at the circus that by
simply holding hands performers can
create tension or ease it circus zonin
dish was founded in nineteen
ninety-seven right now they're getting
ready for their anniversary gala I'm not
active is I'm gonna be really excited on
Monday that's the day of the show Kai's
in charge of the music I'll be doing the
number with the buckets and some
acrobatics pop on stilts right it's a
new outline yeah during the show Sasha
will perform a hip-hop number on stilts
sasha has difficulty speaking that can
make life difficult like when he's
running errands his counselor Dennis
losing her sometimes comes along to help
I don't look like this out there have
you gotten sucked me Shakespeare yeah
art right [ __ ] to fight over what I
take or Ted to fight this like it cuz
that's fine didn't we definitely got
that okay I don't just a second okay
good and here's part two okay great
thanks yeah
Dennis was Inga was able to help Sasha
find what he wanted of course Sasha
would prefer to do things like this on
his own but he can't and sometimes he
gets really angry that he can't express
himself effectively shut it I haven't
seen anything like it when we first
started out sometimes he called me a
jerk but that's just his way of saying
you don't understand I can deal with
that now but a clerk at the supermarket
or the video shop might feel threatened
by that kind of talk and I'm supermarket
or the MV here there its flesh and they
wouldn't understand what's behind it all
so we try to avoid situations like that
undecided mr. stressful I didn't come on
while we still have time I've got
something new Sasha wants to learn to
speak for himself so he's been working
with a speech therapist it's pretty
stressful so he's looking forward to the
end of today's session oh this will be
over soon Sasha uses a mirror to try to
find out what's on the other side of the
card the therapist Miriam's Idol uses
exercises like this to help increase
Sasha's vocabulary and pronunciation
precision wash it runs on Rails ocean I
the train what right does for the joslyn
it's much more difficult for him to
speak clearly than it is for us it's
quite easy for us but for him it's not
death is a strawberry here beer
excellent yeah that's us count how many
there are ok 1 52 53 tie
this is the residential community
where's ahsha lives he's got today off
there's no practice at the circus Sasha
also works as a staff actor at a theater
that features people who have down
syndrome Sasha enjoys watching videos of
some of his performances he dreams one
day of becoming a big star in the zone
inch dish circus
this is the chameleon theater major
international performers appear here
every night but Sasha should probably be
focusing on practicing for the upcoming
circus show on Donna F at 11am will have
a dress rehearsal and run through the
whole first part of the show then we'll
take a break Katarina andreas is the
show's director the cast starts warming
up saying we're so cool we're hot the
hip hoppers aren't using stilts today
because the floor isn't ready yet and of
course every circus performance has to
have a few clowns during the rehearsal a
slapstick almost gets out of hand now
Vanessa split up some people used to say
that we were insulting these people by
putting them on stage these performers
are showcasing their skills and talents
they're demonstrating the gifts that set
them apart I see an analysis in how
they're different from other people but
anyone who thinks that we're insult a
tease people I've putting them on
display should take a closer look I was
fiddle katerina gives some last-minute
direction nice the full fantasy good a
lot of professional performers would
take a look at all this and say I'm not
working under these conditions but our
people get the job done and that's great
they're wide awake to hear something
once and then do it I would call that a
disability they're real professionals
hey Huggins here cool the director and
the cast are ready to continue with the
rehearsal
inhabitat aw before the big show Zasha
stops by his parents house he loves to
cook especially with his mom rozbita
perto wants her son to live a normal
life as best he can but she knows that
some people will ridicule him last week
they were out in the city and a man
stopped and stared at Sasha that he can
feel it when people behave like that he
got pretty upset so I tried to calm him
down people watch you at the circus
setia how does that make you feel how do
you feel about that just like I'm yeah
yeah and then the big evening arrives
the coach goes over the spoken parts
once again with is Asha and Hagen and
talks about why this circus is so
important you couldn't get this I want
to showcase the talents of Sasha Hagen
Lee others yeah we want to see them
shine his I'm Clint look with your head
of it we want them to feel like heroes
when they're on the stage what happens
essa Hagen and Sasha represent the best
of what the zone and Stitch circus has
been able to offer over the past 18
years thanks for being here hmm let's
look to the future the performers are a
little nervous at the answer I'm afraid
of the Stingers tipper what at Kappa
house really he's worried that he might
trip and fall the audience starts to
arrive the place is nearly sold out
behind the scenes the cast is making
last-minute preparations like putting on
their makeup and the shows about to
begin
the circus has helped to make Sasha more
self-confident he's learned to express
himself through movement he doesn't
always have to use words and this is one
place where he can actually enjoy being
the center of attention the circus plans
to move into its own place soon it'll
have a bigger stage and rehearsal rooms
the circus wants to turn even more
people like Sasha portal into
self-confident artists and performers
you